all right let's take a few minutes to
look at this uh the rest of this very
dangerous interview that donald trump
gave to real america's voice you might
recall that about a half hour ago or 40
minutes ago at the start of the show or
earlier in the show we looked at another
request from donald trump to vladimir
putin putin's invading ukraine and trump
says to putin hey can you get me some
dirt on hunter biden that happened
yesterday it's not 2017 or whenever it
was 2016 2015 trump saying hey russia if
you're listening this interview in total
was absolutely sick and disgusting
very clearly donald trump extremely
sensitive about the small size of his
crowd on saturday at his rally listen to
this stanza
they
lie they cheat it's i've never seen
anything like it i never knew it was
that corrupt i knew it was
there was a lot of fake stuff going on
but since i got into politics i've had a
lot of media before you know with the
apprentice and all the things i've done
in the business
but i've never seen anything like it
it's you cannot they will not write a
good story
i have great poll numbers they don't put
them out i have great things happening
like super confident alpha male huh guys
uh just the other day we had a fantastic
rally in georgia
some guy from i think it's npr or
something i never heard of the person
said oh the rally wasn't well attended
the sheriff just said it was 25 000
people he said it was
a couple of thousand people or less than
5 000 people
we had less than 5 000 people and we had
5 000 people in the first few rows i
think you were there your people your
cameramen are just saying yeah sir that
rally was packed they said sir the rally
was just absolutely packed so it was a
very it was it was the smallest crowd
for a trump rally i think in six years
and trump very very sensitive about it
trump continuing to play up the story of
inflation and supply chain issues but
playing it up with just weird talking
points that don't make any sense and of
course it's very clear that trump
doesn't have any idea how the real world
works take a listen to this an example
supply chain
you go to a store they don't have bread
we're like a third world country they
don't have things you go to buy
something at tiffany you're going to buy
something at a hardware store high hello
i love that it's like listen
i don't know that you've ever been to a
grocery store to buy bread and i don't
know that you've ever been to a hardware
store looking for a drywall anchor but
in the middle he says if you go to
tiffany which is not exactly you know
relatable to most people they don't have
product
they say even me when i order things
like for furnishings for a building or
something trump's regularly ordering
tchotchkes off of amazon
they said it's going to take nine months
to get it used to be like same-day
service
um supply chain
we never even heard the term now of
course we did many of us you know in the
business field we back even in business
school we would do case studies on
supply chain but trump says we never
heard it before this is maybe my
favorite part of the interview dave
weigel is a reporter who's a friend of
the show he's a really good guy i've
known dave weigel for a really long time
here trump
doesn't like
what dave weigel had to say check this
out allies you can't even get into him
the people get this six and i have to
put up with this
i had the washington post write a story
that a rally i was giving in an arena
that the arena was empty
it was a man that you know very well in
the washington post
and it was empty about 10 hours before
and he will eventually name dave so just
keep listening sitting there and he
showed an empty thousands of people
outside waiting to get in
and then they came and he had to do an
apology actually because the arena was
packed and you know who went after the
people in the arena
because they saw that it was an empty
arena and you couldn't
i mean they used the the steps as seats
it was thousands and thousands of people
right more than far more than an nba
game
his name was weigel or a wigal for the
washington post and he had to do an
apology
[Laughter]
i can assure you
that dave weigel is absolutely loving
this trump also says democrats are quote
bad on religion
but it's like florida everyone said oh
florida florida
but i won in like a landslide
the way you win is you have to win them
because
when they have
no voter id defund the police sanctuary
cities weak military whether raise your
taxes no energy independence all things
that were
all done
and they're against it now what is
really interesting about this
is every single one of those claims we
could actually go through them you know
one at a time trump actually says if we
look at the subtitles here
uh we have no voter id well actually
there's plenty of places that have voter
id the issue is the implementation of
voter id defund the police no serious
democrats are actually looking to defund
the police sanctuary cities these are
municipal decisions that are made and it
doesn't have anything to do with the
federal government as donald trump uh
claims that it does weak military
democrats keep rubber stamping military
budgets just like do republicans raise
your taxes well not on people earning
under four hundred thousand dollars and
then of course no energy independence we
produced as much oil as we used in 2020
and also in 2021 under joe biden i mean
all of these things are not true but his
followers don't care that we're
all done
and they're against it
bad on religion
bad on the second amendment
bet on oil think of it they said
i'm gonna have a close race in texas
but they're against god
right you just look at it god guns and
oil
i won texas and i'm in a record right no
there was no record actually that trump
won texas
by quite a small margin for a republican
and it's this is the difficulty when we
say we just have to talk to these people
david just talk to these people and
they'll see reason
there are so many lies upon lies i mean
it's a throwaway in here right it's it's
a throwaway that i won texas by a record
no you didn't and it's not even the
point of the actual story and so it
becomes almost a physical impossibility
to unwind the lie upon lie upon lie a
one last clip here and this is an
interesting policy thing it started to
be floated by matt gates the radical
republican congressman under
investigation for child sex trafficking
trump's former propagandist steve bannon
has talked about this what if
republicans win the house in 2022 in a
few months
and then they make donald trump the
speaker of the house because remember
you don't have to
be a member of congress to be speaker of
the house trump actually says here he's
not interested in it oh i want to ask a
follower while we're talking about
congress because these comments went
viral
at the rally when congressman matt gates
brought up you
being nominated for speaker of the house
and i
your reaction intrigued me because i
couldn't tell one way or the other how
you felt about that your reaction
no i think that uh it's not something i
want a lot of people bring it up and
spread up all the time
no it's not something i want to do i
want to look at what's happening and
then we're going to be doing something
else no it's not something we're going
to be doing something else uh you guys
know why trump really doesn't want to be
so okay his ego would not allow him to
go from having been president to being
speaker of the house fine i could
totally get that that makes sense from
an ego standpoint
being speaker of the house
actually is more work
the way trump would have to be doing it
and compared to the way trump did the
job of the president because as
president
in theory you would imagine being
president is a very very busy job
trump had hours of tv time in the
morning and then he would often spend
the afternoon tweeting before he was
banned from twitter and so on and so
forth so it would be a lot more work for
trump to be the speaker of the house but
interesting that he's saying i just
don't want to do it and that basically
puts an end to that discussion if trump
doesn't want to do it he doesn't want to
do it so there's trump very strange
interview
his mood seems sort of altered and
granting just any old interview these
days
um and and i think that we will soon see
a greater level of involvement in the
2022 midterms and it's really important
that the left have a strategy in place
because otherwise they actually as
cartoonishly ignorant as they are
they're going to run away with it unless
the left gets it together
one of our sponsors today is imme the
world's first low carb high protein 100
percent plant-based instant ramen emmy
has only six net carbs perfect if you're
doing keto or low carb unlike regular
ramen it has 21 grams of protein helping
you feel fuller longer 18 grams of fiber
that's four times more than most other
ramen brands and emmy also has 35
percent less sodium than competitors so
you don't get that bloat and thirst imi
uses only high quality ingredients they
don't use a lot of preservatives that
many other ramen brands use i love
making imi ramen as a snack just like
any other instant ramen you put it in
the microwave ready in a few minutes i
love adding green onion and mushrooms to
it emmy comes in spicy beef tom yum
shrimp black garlic chicken i've tried
all three they're all delicious and
they're plant-based right now emmy is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below